there is no struggle what's wrong with
this I mean come on enjoy a little well
what's wrong with it is there is nothing
right with it metabolic diseases that
are associated with obesity the diabetes
the heart disease the lipid problems the
strokes the cancer those diseases are
being driven by sugar I want to honor my
body with the very best quality and
nutrition that is available to me the
very best nutrition that God nature have
to office well God had given us this is
not going to have a nutritional effect
on your body no nutrition in there it's
gonna have a drug like effect on your
body
guess what gets in the way of that job
sugar when you indulge in soft drinks
and junk food your brain is a hard time
recognizing leptin so you stay hungry
longer and eat more than you should
turning children into into addicts for
sweets because they project their own
food preferences and their own
addictions on the children and then and
then the children become addicts for
sugar in some form but now but sixty
percent of the population is overweight
or obese and diabetes rates have tripled
Oh
as Muslims you know it's pork we stay
totally away from the first reason has
to do with the digestive system of a pig
pigs are the filthiest animals on earth
with the most parasites and diseases
than any other animal that mankind can
use but call this nutrition 101 okay if
you want to be real healthy then use 23
sachets of sugar in that single
container when you consider heart
disease and liver disease both of which
can be caused by sugar
yeah sugar has more of a drug like
effect it's a stimulant it is why I can
respect their I can I can I can respect
alcohol important part of Hallel and I
have a lot of appreciation for that you
know about hello yes oh all right I
don't forget as I asked you to do
already if you have it subscribed right
now